We'd like to now calculate
the angular momentum
about an axis rotation of a
symmetric object like a ring.
So here is our axis of rotation.
We're going to have
omega pointing up.
That means omega's z will
be positive, because that's
going to be our k hat axis.
And this is a ring of
mass m and radius r.
So here's our radius.
Now, and we're going
to choose a point that
lies somewhere on the
symmetry axis of the ring.
And the object is rotating
about that symmetry axis.
So it's passing through
the center of mass.
Now, the way we'll
do this is we'll
divide our ring up into
pairs of symmetric objects.
So we have an m here and
a little delta m there.
And we're going to calculate
the angular momentum
first of that pair.
Well, we've already
made that calculation
that the angular momentum
about s of the pair
is twice the mass
of each object.
That's the mass of the
pair times r squared
and it points in
the omega direction.
And so to get the angular
momentum of the ring,
we'll just sum up a
set of symmetric pairs
until we expand out
over the entire ring.
And so L of the
ring about s is just
the sum over the pairs
of the mass of the pair
times r squared omega.
And r squared and omega
are all constants.
The total mass of
the ring is just
the sum over the pairs
of the mass of the pair.
And that's the total
mass m of the ring.
And so what we get is m r
squared omega L of the ring s.
This is the moment of inertia
about the axis for the ring,
because all the mass is
distributed a distance r away.
And so we see for a continuous
symmetric body like a ring,
again, because it's symmetric,
the angular momentum
only has a component along
the axis of rotation.
Now, what if we had an
extended symmetric object?
And let's see if I can possibly
draw something like that.
So we'll draw a
pear shaped object.
What is the moment of inertia of
this pear shaped object, which
is intended to be
symmetric, about the z-axis?
Well, I can think of
that pear shaped object
as consisting of a ring
and it's a solid object.
This is a solid
symmetric object.
And then inside the
ring is just more rings.
So the whole disk here is
just a superposition of rings.
And so the moment of inertia--
so the angular momentum
of just this disk
is the moment of the
disk about the axis.
And now I'll just add more
disks that are symmetric.
And so by exactly
the same calculation
as I have here, the moment of
this symmetric object is just--
the moment of inertia is more
complicated for this object.
And it points in
the omega direction.
So again, in conclusion,
a symmetric object
about the axis of
rotation only has
a component of L pointing
in the direction of omega.
The constant of proportionality
between the angular momentum
and the angle the
velocity is the moment
of inertia about that axis.
This we need to calculate
for each symmetric object.